MANASA CHALASANI:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to this session on
proactive network operations
using Network
Intelligence Center.
My name is Manasa Chalasani.
I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud
in Cloud networking team.
And I focus on products
related to network performance,
monitoring, diagnostics.
And I have with me here Gargi.
GARGI ADHAV: Thank you, Manasa.
Hi everyone, this
is Gargi Adhav.
I [INAUDIBLE] engineering
in cloud networking,
and Network
Intelligence Center is
one of the initiatives my
team is still contributing to.
MANASA CHALASANI: So
I want to start off
with sharing a little bit more
about what we heard from all
of you around the problem
statements regarding
network operations,
monitoring, and diagnostics.
And the first thing we
heard from all of you
is, basically, the lack of
comprehensive, single pane
of glass view for anything
related to network
troubleshooting and monitoring.
Today, you had to move between
various panes of glass,
be it home-grown tools
or on-prem tools,
or various third-party
cloud monitoring tools.
And you had to stitch all
that information together.
And what that led to was
that, at some places,
you had to actually spend a
lot of time-- sometimes days--
to be able to figure out and
investigate these issues.
And that problem was
even more complicated
when it came to your
hybrid deployments,
specifically troubleshooting
on-prem to our Cloud.
Another key point
that we heard from you
was that you did
not have visibility
into real-time network
performance metrics.
One other point that
came up from all of you
was that a lot of
times, when you push out
these configuration
changes continuously
in your environment, it was very
difficult to understand what
is the impact of those
configuration changes
that you push out to
firewalls, routing,
load balancer, et cetera.
And that might, again,
increase your time
that you take to
investigate any issues that
would have been caused because
of these config changes.
So overall, what
we heard was you
needed a single, kind
of intelligent platform
that helps you
monitor your network,
provide visibility,
and provide you
diagnostics to help your
day-to-day operations
perspective.
So we took all of that feedback.
And from ground up, we built
the Network Intelligence Center.
It's the comprehensive network
monitoring, verification,
and optimization platform
offered by Google Cloud.
And the focus, again, is to
offer you all the visibility
and reduce the time you take
to be able to troubleshoot
any network issue.
We're starting off
with four modules,
which we will go through as
a part of this presentation--
network topology, performance
dashboard, connectivity test,
and firewall insights.
These start off
with providing you
with the visibility and
monitoring of your network,
as well as troubleshooting
tools for diagnosing
any issues quickly.
But this is just a start, and
there will be more modules
that you can continue to
introduce as part of Network
Intelligence Center, as we
move towards providing you
with further insights,
and recommendations,
and optimizations
for your network.
And I want to also
quickly mention
that the Network Intelligence
Center is actually
part of Active Assist, which
is a brand new solution that's
being offered by Google Cloud
that focuses on reducing
the complexity of your
overarching cloud environment,
by providing you with a variety
of intelligent and proactive
features.
Towards the end of
the presentation,
we will give you more
details around Active Assist
and other sessions that you
could get more information
on this, as well.
So with that, let's start
off with the first module,
network topology.
Network topology is
a visualization off
your global GCP deployment.
It shows actual communications
between various networking
nodes, like compute instances,
to the public internet
and also to network services
like load balancers, NAT, et
cetera.
And it also shows you all of
the associated performance
metrics for all of those edges.
And all of these metrics, as
well as the topology itself,
we are able to capture and
track over a period of time--
over six weeks--
so that you can actually
see how each of these
evolve over a period of time
and generate insights from that.
Next, let's move to how you
can use network topology.
These are some of
the common use cases
that we saw our customers
using network topology.
The first one is
network monitoring.
So this is where
customers made sure
that the topology that they
viewed here within the Network
Intelligence Center was in
line with what the intent was
by the network
team, as they were
deploying that infrastructure.
And so that could mean
things like, for example,
if you want all of
your compute instances
to talk to the public
internet through load balances
and not directly,
that's something
that you can very easily
check using this product.
Or you can very quickly check if
all of your, say, for example,
Asia users are being served
from the closest region to them
or not.
The second use case is around
network troubleshooting.
So network topology has a
very fast and quick filtering
capability, where in
case, for example, you
are troubleshooting as
best network issue related
to an instance or
a load balance,
you can filter for
that specific instance
and view all of the
traffic, as well as
metrics, associated with that.
We have the instance
very quickly,
as well as see what that looked
like at the point of time
of the incident, because you're
saving the topology itself
over a period of time.
The third use case is
architecture optimization.
So in our architecture
optimization,
once the customers
actually understand
what the architecture
looks like,
they can now very quickly
perform optimizations
at cost or performance.
For example, being
able to understand
what your traffic looks
like between various regions
can help you optimize
egress traffic.
The next one is tracking
workload migration.
So as you're moving your
resources onto the Cloud,
topology provides
you a very easy
to understand how your
deployment is evolving,
what are the performance
metrics associated,
so that you can
tweak your deployment
architecture to optimize
for performance, or cost,
or availability.
The fifth one is
around compliance--
checks and audits.
Export this topology to be
able to use some of this
as part of your SOC
audits, without requiring
any third-party tools.
This is a very quick
capture of what
network topology looks like.
On the top, you
have countries which
have captured external
clients, public internet.
In the middle are
load balancers,
which you can click through
to understand all the load
balancers you have deployed.
And at the bottom
are GCP regions
where you have your
compute instances deployed.
And you can drill down all
the way to the VM instance.
All of these edges
capture metrics,
and you can click
through to understand
exactly how those
metrics evolved
for each of those edges.
Now, let's move on to the
next product with the Network
Intelligence Center called
Performance Dashboard.
Our Performance Dashboard
provides real-time performance
metrics, like latency and
packet loss, for your project
and for your set of VMs.
So this reflects the customer's
actual experience within GCP.
We look at all of the
VM-to-VM performance metrics
and aggregate it to
a zone level to be
able to show you what the
inter-zone latency and packet
loss looks like for your
project and your environment.
So what that means is whenever
there is a, for example,
you're investigating
an application issue,
you can very quickly understand
if this is a network level
issue or not and take
a call based upon that.
These metrics will be available
over the Project Performance
dashboard, which is now GA.
It is part of your Network
Intelligence Center console.
It will also be available as
part of our network topology,
as part of the edges
that we just saw.
As well as our
metrics are concerned,
we are cloud
monitoring, where you
can set up alerts as per your
requirements and use cases.
Now, I will move on to show
the demo of the Performance
Dashboard.
Now, let's get
started with the demo.
So the way to get to
Performance Dashboard
is you go to your console.
Under Networking, you will
find Network Intelligence
and Performance Dashboard there.
You can click through that.
Performance Dashboard
is a GA product,
so you should be able to
view this at your end.
And what you'll see here
is packet loss and latency
for your set of VMs and your
specific project itself.
So it's your experience
of the network.
And on this chart here, you
will see the average packet loss
across all of your zone pairs
where you have VMs deployed,
and also the packet loss
for the highest loss zone
pair for any given sample.
So now, if I want to
investigate further,
let's click through and
zoom in on this timeframe
and see what's happening
at this specific timeframe.
Now, when I clicked on that,
a two-by-two chart matrix
shows up.
And you'll see
all of these zones
are basically the zones where
you have your VMs deployed.
And here, I see that
there's a specific packet
loss recorded between Asia
east 1B and Europe west 2C.
Now, I can click
through further here
to understand for this specific
zone pair, what the packet
loss was over a period of time.
And this metric is
recorded over six weeks,
so you can view
that over six weeks.
Now, I can zoom in further here
and understand that this packet
loss was recorded at 9:41.
And at 9:40 and
9:42, it was at zero.
So what this enables
you to answer
is, whenever there is any
application where issue
is happening, you can go
back here and understand
if this was related
to a network issue
or not, and also how
long did it last.
Now going back
here, similarly, you
can access latency
information as well.
And you have similar charts
available for latency.
And also you can
see median latency
across all of these
zone pairs where
you have your VMs deployed,
at any point in time.
With that, let's move back to
the rest of the presentation
and the other modules.
With that, next, I want to also
call out the Live Public Google
Cloud Inter-region Performance
Dashboard that we recently
launched.
This shows inter-region
performance metrics, latency,
and throughput for all of
our inter-region traffic
using PerfKit Benchmarker.
PerfKit Benchmarker is
an open-source toolkit
provided by Google, but it
has 100 plus contributors.
And the key thing to this is
it utilizes the common aspects
of performance testing, like
ping, network, [INAUDIBLE]..
But what it does it is it
automates a lot of the process
that I'm testing.
So it automates a process
around provisioning your VMs,
setting up the VPC,
setting up firewall rules,
as well as at the end
of the test, [INAUDIBLE]
entire infrastructure.
And this dashboard also provides
a tutorial into how exactly
you can reproduce
any of these metrics.
We are providing this use
so that you can make calls
around where to deploy your
resources so that you can
optimize for performance
within Google Cloud
and provide that visibility
to make those decisions.
With that, I will
hand it over to Gargi.
GARGI ADHAV: Thank you, Manasa.
So the next module
we will talk about
is called connectivity test.
So one of the biggest pinpoints
that we heard from customers
during our research, and
like Manasa mentioned,
was the lack of
troubleshooting capabilities.
And when we did a
survey of the customers,
it turns out that almost
75% of our network failures
and performance
issues are resulting
from configuration errors.
And once these network
failures happen,
it is really hard to pinpoint
and troubleshoot a root cause
as to where the
problem was happening.
And that itself
takes a long time,
and it increases
the outage period.
So one of the biggest
requests from customers
was that if you
could just tell us
whether the root cause of
the failure is at Google,
or is it us, or
is it the network.
That itself would
be a huge value.
The other problem was
that it's very hard
to understand that
when any of your admins
are making configuration
changes, what is
going to be the impact of it--
whether these are rock
solid config changes,
or is something going to fail?
So The What of the
connectivity test
is a tool to help you
diagnose connectivity issues--
before you can
actually do it, or even
after you have done it--
saying, these are the
configs that have changed,
and as a result, these are the
failures of between a source
or destination, or to
even validate that,
yes, this the flow that
you were expecting,
and it is doing it
as you expected.
How do we do it?
So we don't actually run
a ping or a trace route,
so this is complete static
modeling of your network using
all your configuration files,
and your routing information,
and so on.
So here's an example
of a connectivity test.
You can have source
and [? S ?] protocols
or protocol and ports.
Either you can
specify an IP address
as a source and destination,
or you can have VMs--
a source VM and a des VM,
with their respective ports,
which is optional, and
also protocol feeding,
which is optional.
And what we give to you is
a step-by-step visualization
about what pack your
packet would be taking
and what configuration
it would be hitting.
So in this case, it is
starting from a VM instance.
There is an egress firewall
that it hits, which it passes.
Then there is a
static route look up
that happens, which it passes.
And then there is a NAT lookup,
which is where it fails.
Maybe there is a
missing NAT route.
So here are a few examples
of connectivity tests
that we have shown, like
different paths that it
can take.
The first one is it goes
through a firewall rule.
It is successful.
And if there is no
reason for the failure
and it says the
packet is dropped,
it could also be that it goes
outside your IAM policy domain
that it allows you.
And you may want to reach
out to your super admin who
has the policies because
[INAUDIBLE] between both
of you, you could
understand the reason.
The second example,
in this case,
it is going through
a firewall rule
and then it is getting dropped.
In the third
example, it is it is
going through a load balancer
and then it is getting dropped.
And the fourth one is
a successful example
that we have taken, where
it goes to a VPN tunnel
and then it all
comes in and will
show you the different steps,
just a traceroute would.
Except that in this
case, a traceroute
shows IP addresses,
versus here, you
see all the steps of
the configurations
that would be executed on that
packet-- be it a VPN tunnel,
be it a routing lookup,
be it a NAT rule look up,
or a firewall rule.
And in case of a NAT or firewall
rule failure or even a success,
it will tell you exactly
which rule it hit
and why it was a
success or a failure.
So you could go
back in real time
and say, oh, this firewall
rule is accidentally
blocking this packet.
And that's not what I intended.
You go change that, and then
you will see immediately
that your packet
flow is successful.
So let's talk about
the next module.
This is called
Firewall Insights.
So one of the other challenges
that we heard from many of you
is around firewalls and the
management of firewall rules.
Several people have
thousands and thousands
of firewall rules, and if
they wanted to optimize that,
they did not know
where to start.
Because usually what
we heard was that there
is a series of admins.
Some security admin in the past
must have created this firewall
rule, and they went ahead
to a different rule,
and new security admins came on.
And we said, then
how do you figure out
which rules are still active?
They said, oh, we do not
delete firewall rules.
We just add them.
So that makes the firewall
rules very unmanageable,
and you don't even
know where to start.
So as a result, you end
up with a massive volume
of firewall rules.
And sometimes there is
over-granting of rules,
because you just granted at a
higher level IP address range,
even though you may only be
partially using some of it.
There is also human
error, of course.
And there is no
way to figure out,
unless there is an actual
traffic drop, that something
bad had happened.
And then the other thing,
like we talked about,
is outdated rules,
because people
are too afraid to change
them, mainly going back
to they don't know
what else could break
and what was the
intention of this rule,
for why it was created.
So Firewall Insights took
on all of these problems.
And we said, OK, let's tackle
that by applying intelligence
to the data that we have and
the configurations that we have.
So one of the first
things that we have done
is give you visibility
into usage metrics based
on each firewall
rule, like what has
been the hit rate in the past
x number of days, and so on.
And you can see the hit
count, the timestamp,
and you can export this.
This data is exported
to Stackdriver where
you can set your own alerts.
The other part is,
through analysis
and applying some symbolic
analysis on the config data,
we are able to show you what is
the hierarchical relationship
among different tools.
Which rule is
shadowing another rule?
Like for example, there
is a high-priority slash
16 rule, and then there are
three low-priority slash 24
rules, are obviously
being shadowed.
Slash 16 is shadowing
the lower priority rules.
And as a result,
you could easily
get rid of the underlying
three allow rules,
because you have an
overarching allow
rule that is addressing this
allow functionality or desire.
So that's a very simple
example of optimization.
But then there are other
more complex examples.
So we analyze all of that.
And we show you the shadowing
and shadowed relationship
among the rules.
And then, as a result, we allow
you to strengthen your firewall
control by even
recommending to you
or showing you insights on
where some of your security
could be tightened,
by showing you
that these are the only
rules which are being hit.
So there are two
ends of the spectrum.
On one end of the
spectrum, you are
able to optimize
your firewall rules.
And on the other
end of the spectrum,
you're able to strengthen
your security by making
the rules more specific.
And you could do both, based
on what your desire is.
Now, we'll go to the demo
for Firewall Insights.
Firewall Insights provides
you three main things today.
Firstly, it shows you the
different relationships
among your firewall rules--
the shadowing, shadowed
conflicting relationships.
Secondly, it shows you which of
your deny rules have been hit,
and thirdly, which
of your allowed rules
have not been hit
in the last 60 days.
As we discussed,
firewall rules can
be added by different
people over time,
causing new rules to be
accidentally overshadowed
by existing rules,
or vice versa.
Without any automated detection,
this is really hard to do.
So for example, if there is a
VM 1 in a 10.1 slash 24 subnet,
which cannot reach VM 2 in a
10.2 slash 24 subnet when you
intended it to, the first thing
you would do is run a ping
test.
So you go to VM 1 and
you can ping 10.2.0.2
and see what happens.
The ping failed.
So let's see what could
be the root cause of this.
So to troubleshoot,
you would go to VM2
and view the network
details to see
what are the configurations
that are applied on VM2.
And you see, oh,
there is a 10.1 slash
16 deny firewall rule which
is shadowing a 10.1 slash 24
allow firewall rule,
naturally causing your traffic
to be blocked and thus break.
There could be multiple
such instances that
are in your firewall rules.
And if you have
thousands of them,
it's really hard to
automatically detect and find
these conflicts.
So Firewall Insights in
Network Intelligence Center
provides you exactly that.
It gives you a list of all your
shadowed rules in your firewall
conflicts, in your VPC, that
you can audit and figure out
which ones to clean and
keep, or which ones to keep.
So a single rule
or multiple rules
can be blocked by multiple or
a combination of other rules.
In this case, an allow
rule to TCP ports 18243
are being blocked by, or
shadowed by, or denied
by old rule, actually causing
this breakage to happen.
So you may want to proactively
audit all those shadowed rules
in your firewall
conflicts and figure out
which ones match your
traffic needs and intent,
and which ones don't and
you don't want to keep,
and clean those up.
The second powerful thing that
Firewall Insights provides
is a list of allow
rules that have not
been hit in the last six weeks.
So you could come here to view
a full list of these rules.
So as you can see, there are
multiple rules that have not
been hit in the last six weeks.
And if you ordered
these, these could
be rules left over
by past applications
where someone forgot
to clean them up.
So in this case, there is a
web app 1 which has a firewall
allow rule for a 0
slash 0 IP address.
And it's not been hit
in the last six weeks,
so naturally, web app
1 probably went away
and this got left over as a
vestige hole in your network.
So reviewing these rules will
help you tighten your security
boundaries.
The third powerful function
that is provided to you
is the deny rules with hits.
Now, this could point to
unintended, abnormal traffic
behaviors.
It could even be attacks
into your network.
And to figure out where these
attacks are coming from,
you could go to the
firewall logs, corresponding
to the firewall rules, and see
where the source of the traffic
is.
And especially when you have
a large, abnormal behavior,
you may want to look
into that traffic source.
Even there is a
misconfiguration,
or there is an attack
coming from those sources.
In summary, Firewall
Insights gives you
four powerful functions.
Firstly, it gives you
real time visibility
into your firewall rules
utilization and stats.
Secondly, it automatically
detects overlapping
and misconfigured
firewall rules.
Thirdly, it helps you optimize
your firewall conflicts
by enabling you to
delete any shadowing,
shadowed, conflicting, or
unused firewall rules that
do not match your intent.
And finally, it helps
you tighten your security
boundaries by detecting any
unused vestige rules that
may be creating holes
in your network.
Through a combination
of all these,
Firewall Insights thus helps
you to optimize and maintain
the right set of firewall
rules to protect your cloud
deployments.
So to wrap up, we have launched
the Network Intelligence
Center, which has [INAUDIBLE]
It includes all the four
modules that Manasa and
I talked about today,
on network topology, and
performance dashboard,
connectivity test,
and Firewall Insights.
So as you can see, we
are taking an approach
of proactive intelligence,
proactively monitoring
and operating your network,
on shortening the outages that
happen in a network.
And as a result, then you
come to trust the GCP network
intelligence more--
build trust and basically help
you manage your network better.
So as next steps, here
are some related sessions.
There is a Cloud is
Complex session that you
should definitely attend.
It's related.
What's New in
Network Security, it
will talk to you about
the overall security
initiative from GCP.
And it will talk about
firewalls at an [? uber ?] level
and also delve into
Firewall Insights.
And if you want, you
could reach out to us
at Network Intelligence
Center at google.com
and follow our blog on
products/networking.
Thank you.